i hate to have to start here today but i
have a
sort of um epidemiological
gun to my head for uh metaphorical
purposes
called the delta variant and called
anti-vaxxerism
and it's just bad news about this
pandemic that we just
can't seem to shake thanks to people
refusing to get vaccinated
and thanks to the highly contagious
delta variant average daily cases
here in the united states are up 122
in just over three weeks more than
doubling
in just three weeks up from their bottom
of about 12 000 cases a day we had
gotten down
to about 12 000 cases a day by the way
still more than the 10 000 case
per day mark that dr anthony fauci
established over a year ago as sort of
like
we need to get below that to say it's
under control we almost got down to that
and now cases back up 122 to about 27
000 a day this
is really quick and it's because of the
rapidly spreading
60 more contagious delta variant
combined
with too many people just choosing not
to get vaccinated there's vaccines
everywhere they're coming
out there you you can't walk through a
pharmacy without
just stumbling over vaccines and
20 percent of the country just not
interested and the good news is and
we'll get back to this if you are
vaccinated
you were really well protected against
the delta variant if you are vaccinated
and you get the virus in one of these
what are called breakthrough infections
you're likely not to have symptoms and
if you do have a symptomatic vaccinated
case
it's likely not to be serious you're not
likely to be hospitalized you're not
likely to die but nothing is perfect
everything is bell curve distribution
and some vaccinated people
who do everything right will get sick
and they will die
and every person who chooses not to get
vaccinated makes that
more likely we wondered though cases are
up
but will deaths be up because with so
many people vaccinated we might see
cases but we won't see deaths go up
we said three weeks ago we need three
weeks to answer that question because
death's lag cases by three weeks and
sadly the answer there is yes as well
you have to look carefully because it's
still a small
uptick in terms of raw numbers but on a
percentage basis
deaths are now up almost 20 percent
deaths per day in the u.s from covid
bottomed out about a week ago
at 218 per day they have ticked back
up 20 to 259 per day
we have only fully vaccinated about half
of the united states
if you look at vaccinations per day you
see at the
that we are now back down to the daily
vaccination levels
of early january when we had almost no
vaccine availability
we're now doing a pathetic flaccid
week 500 000 doses a day
we have all the vaccines you can just
walk in almost anywhere
and we're only doing 500 000 doses a day
and since many of those are
parts of a two-dose regimen we're really
only
completing a vaccination protocol for
probably about 350 000
people per day 0.1 percent of the
population per day
it's humiliating it's pathetic and the
virus is spreading
it's not some abstract thing oh
vaccinations are down but it has no real
impact case is up 122
that's up almost 20 percent not just
happening in the us although it's
particularly bad here
globally cases are now back up
31 from their low globally
deaths are now back up about three
percent from their low remember deaths
follow cases by three to four weeks
nearly half of republicans
in the united states just don't want the
vaccine
people in other countries are falling
all over themselves to try to get the
limited vaccines that are available
and in the united states nearly half of
republicans say nah i don't want to go
and get it
it's horrifying stuff dr eric topel who
has been a guest on the program before
posted to his twitter
there are places in the united states
with vaccination rates
as low as 15 1-5
newton-misura 16 vaccination
douglas 15 reynolds 15
this is unconscionable now if there is
any good news we'll go back to something
i mentioned at this at the top of the
segment
it is once again the reassurance
that the vaccines work really well
we can't control the fact that even as
vaccinated people
we are more at risk thanks to people who
refuse to get vaccinated that we can't
we can't directly control we can try to
convince them but we can't change the
math of that
but being able to get vaccinated oneself
is a big piece because the latest
numbers are that
99 of those
who are currently hospitalized are
unvaccinated people so
the level of protection that you can
unilaterally give yourself
just by going and getting getting
vaccinated is absolutely huge
it's not perfect but it's absolutely
huge and that's the reassuring thing
the hope would be and this is
you know depending on whether you look
at pfizer or moderna
and you look at it there's a lot of
details in this the hope would be
maybe by the end of fall by winter
maybe not until early 2022 the vaccine
that will be available will be one that
is already tailored
for the delta variant but as we know
the more it spreads the more opportunity
to mutate and to go to some new variant
that the vaccine will not be tailored to
there's now talk of this lambda variant
from australia we don't know much about
it there's the possibility that it's
even more contagious than delta
we don't know about the mortality rate
these are all questions and because we
don't have answers to those questions
what question do we have an answer to
right now well the question is
how can you give yourself drastic
protection
and protect others it's just you go and
get vaccinated it's that simple
so it's depressing i'm not going to lie
it is very very depressing
but um it is where we are today
and uh hopefully we will be able to
accelerate vaccination i don't know what
it'll take at this point i know that a
third of those who say i don't want it
say
if it's rece if it receives full
approval from the fda
i will go and get vaccinated one-third
of those who don't currently want the
vaccine say
i will get it if it gets full uh
authorization full approval from the fda
that's coming soon so we will soon see
if we are going to see that
for the longest time i was having
trouble finding snacks
that are healthy but actually taste
great and fill me up and satisfy
a craving and that's why it's great that
i stumbled upon
monk pack and we asked them to be one of
our sponsors
monk pack keto nut and seed bars are
delicious snacks that have one gram of
sugar or less
only two to three grams of net carbs and
just 150 calories perfect for a
keto or low carb diet or anybody who
like me
just prefers to eat a low sugar diet i
love the monk pack keto nut
and seed bars because it's really just a
great balance of sweet and salty
soft and chewy but with a nice crunch
from the nuts and seeds
flavors include caramel or caramel
you tell me sea salt sea salt dark
chocolate and peanut butter dark
chocolate that's my favorite
they'll give you all of your money back
if you don't love it go to monkpack.com
the link is down below
and they'll give you 20 off any of their
products when you use coupon code pacman